to have some matrix a
let's say a is n by n so it looks
something like this you've seen this
before a 1 1 a 1 2 all the way to a
1 n when you go down the rows you get
a21 that goes all the way to a to n and
let's say that there's some row here
let's say row i it looks like a i1 all
the way to a i
and then you have some other row here a
j
it's aj1 all the way to a
jn and then you keep going all the way
down to a
n 1
a
n 2 all the way to a
n n this is just an n by n matrix and
you can see that i took a little trouble
to write out my row a my i throw here
and my j throat here and just to kind of
keep things a little simple let me just
define
let me just define just for notational
purposes you can view these as row
vectors if you like but i haven't
formally defined row vectors so i won't
necessarily go there but let's just
define the term ri we'll call that row i
to be equal to
a i 1
a i
all the way to
a
i n and you can write it as a vector if
you like like a row vector we haven't
really defined operations on row vectors
that well yet but i think you get the
idea we can then replace this guy with
r1 this guy with r2 all the way down let
me do that and i'll do that in the next
couple of videos because it'll simplify
things i think make things a little bit
easier to understand so i can rewrite
this matrix
this n by n matrix a i can rewrite it
as just
r
i actually the since this looks like a
cop a vector it's just a a row vector
let me write it as a
vector like that and i'm being a little
bit hand wavy here because all of our
vectors have been defined as column
vectors but i think you get the idea so
let's call that r1
and then we have r2 is the next row all
the way down you keep going down you get
to ri that's this row right there
ri you keep going down you get r
j
you get rj and then you keep going down
until you get to the nth row and each of
these guys are going to have n terms
because you have n columns
so that's another way of writing the
same n by n matrix
now what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to create a new matrix let's call
that
swapping
the swap matrix of
i and j so i'm going to swap i and j
those two rows so what's the matrix
going to look like
everything else is going to be equal
you have
row one assuming that one wasn't one of
the irjs it could have been
row two
all the way down to now instead of a row
i there you have a row j there
you have a row j and you go down instead
of a row j you have a row i there
you have a row i there and you go down
and then you get an r n
so what did we do we just swapped these
two guys that's what the swap matrix is
now i think it was in the last video or
a couple of videos ago we learned that
if you just swap two rows of any n by n
matrix what you get or the determinant
of the resulting matrix will be the
negative of the original determinant so
we get the determinant
the determinant of s
the swap of the ith and the j rows is
going to be equal to the minus of the
determinant of a
the minus of the determinant of a now
let me ask you an interesting question
what is what happens if those two rows
were actually the same what if
ri was equal to rj
so if we go back to that all of these
guys
if that row is equal to this row
if that row is equal to that row that
means that this guy is equal to that guy
that the second
guy the second column is equal to the
second column for that row all the way
to the nth guy is equal to the nth guy
that's what i mean when i say what
happens if those row two rows are equal
each other well if those two rows are
equal to each other then this matrix is
no different than this matrix here even
though we swapped them if you swap two
identical things you're just going to be
left with the same thing again so if if
let me write this down
if
row
i is equal to rho
j then this guy
then s
the swapped matrix is equal to
a they'll be identical you're swapping
two rows that are the same thing
so that implies
that implies the determinant of
the swapped matrix is equal to the
determinant
determinant of a
but we just said it's the swap matrix
when you swap two rows it equals a
negative of the determinant of a so this
tells us it also has to equal it also
has to equal the negative of the
determinant of a
so what does that tell us
that tells us if a has two rows that are
equal to each other if a wrote has two
rows that are equal to each other if we
swap them it should we should get the
negative of the determinant but if those
two rows are equal we're going to get
the same matrix again
so if a has two rows that are equal
so if row i is equal to row j then the
determinant of a has to be equal to the
negative of the determinant of a we know
that because the determinant of a or a
is the same thing as a swapped version
of a and the swap version of a has to
have the negative determinant of a so
these two things have to be equal now
what number is equal to a negative
version of itself if i just told you x
is equal to negative x what number does
x have to be equal to there's only one
value that it could possibly be equal to
x would have to be x would have to be
equal to zero so the takeaway here is
if one row or let's say if you have
duplicate rows
you could extend this if you have three
or four rows that are same duplicate
rows
lead you to the fact that the
determinant of your matrix is
zero and that really shouldn't be a
surprise because if you have duplicate
rows remember what we learned a long
time ago we learned that we learned that
a matrix is an invertible
matrix
invertible
if and only if
if and only if the reduced row echelon
form
is
the identity is the identity matrix we
learned that but if you have two
duplicate rows
if you have two duplicate rows let's say
these two guys are equal to each other
you could perform a row operation where
you replace this guy with this guy minus
that guy and you'll just get a row of
zeros and if you get a row of zeros
you're never going to be able to get the
identity matrix
so duplicate
so we know that a duplicate
duplicate
rows
could never
never
get
reduced row echelon form to be
the identity or duplicate rows are not
invertible
are not
are non-invertible and we also learned
that something is not invertible if and
only if its determinant is equal to zero
if its determinant is equal to zero so
we now got to the same result two
different ways one we just used some of
what we learned when you swap rows it
should become the negative but if you
swap the same row you shouldn't change
the matrix so the determinant of the
matrix has to be the same as itself so
if you have duplicate rows and
determined is zero which
isn't something that we had to use using
this little swapping technique we could
have gone back to our uh our
requirements for invertibility uh i
think it was five or six videos ago but
i just wanted to point that out if you
see duplicate rows and actually if you
see duplicate columns i'll leave that
for you to think about if you see
duplicate rows or duplicate columns or
even you see that some rows are are
linear combinations of other rows and
i'm not showing that to you right here
then you know that your determinant is
going to be equal to zero